تجربه اجرتها شركه 5 سكويرلز البريطانيه
لمنتجات العنايه بالبشره اعتمدت العمل
لمده اربعه ايام في الاسبوع فقط دون زياده
ساعات العمل اليوميه منذ يونيو الماضي
يقول جاري كونري مالك الشركه ان موظفيه
الخمسه عشره نجحوا في تحقيق الاهداف
المطلوبه منهم ورفع الانتاجيه بل تراجعت
حتى شكاوى العملاء بالفعل هذه الشركه على
فكره ليست الوحيده التي تطبق تجربه اربعه
ايام عمل بدلا من خمسه بل نفذتها ضمن حمله
اطلقت بدايه العام في بريطانيا الحمله
شاركت فيها
احداث وستون شركه لديها اقل من 25 عاملا
بعد التجربه لمده سته اشهر اعتمدت 56 شركه
هذه السياسه بصوره دائمه
[موسيقى]
واحنا اصلا ليش نروح بعيد اصلا لبريطانيا
ما عنا اماره الشارقه من اكثر من سنه ونصف
وهي بتعتمد نظام العمل باربعه ايام فقط
وهذا لم يؤثر على الانتاجيه بتاتا بحسب ما
بتتحدث يعني حكومه الشارقه وعلى ما يبدو
بانه مطروح هذا الموضوع في دول اخرى راح
نكون مبسوطين على فكره
مبسوط احنا راح نسال ايضا طبعا سمر لديها
الاجابه جهينه في صباح العربيه لكن خلينا
خلينا نروح الى لبنان قبل ذلك سالنا الناس
هناك اذا لديك يوم اجازه اضافي في الاسبوع
فراح تستغله طويله
[موسيقى]
ممكن اروح بقى الاماكن لسه ما رحتهاش يعني
بس يعني لو كنت موجود يوم زياده كنت هصحى
الصبح بدري وانزل البحر
بس كده اذا كان نهار فرصه زياده بدي
نشتغلوا لانه شايف المعيشه كيف صايره هاي
هي معمل لحق يعني
بمشي
رياضه
بحب الرياضه
مضعف حالي لو كان عندي يوم فرصه زياده
بالاسبوع بطلع انا وحبيبتي وامي والعائله
يعني هيك لو كان عندي يوم زياده بظهر مع
عيلتك ما بخليها يوم ما بروح بكزدر فيه
يعني اقل شيء شو بدي اعمل
نعيش نشوف الحياه انا اشتغلت اربعين سنه
بالكولاج
ما كنت اعرف شو في برا بس هلا بحب بيتي ما
بحب اظهر اذا صح لي يوم زياده بالجمعه
اكيد بقضيه معاي
نحن قاعدين عاطلين عن العمل شو بدي اعمل
فيه نحن
حتى نشتغل حتى بالبلد
[موسيقى]
يوم ثلاث ايام
والله انا استثمر يوم لازم يكون للراحه
عشان احس انه انا بجد يوم للبيت ولولاد
والاسره ويوم لالي
سمر
الصحفيه في قسم الاقتصاد ربما ترى ان ذلك
صحيا ولا غير صحي ولا ينطبق على الشركات
لديها عدد قليل من الموظفين
او علميا التجربه لما تم تطبيقها مثل ما
شفنا بالمقدمه يعني اغلب الشركات اللي
تبنوا التجربه بقوا على مبدا الاربع ساعات
بس كانت الشركات اللي نجحت بزياده
الانتاجيه او خلينا نقول قياس الانتاجيه
هي الاقل من 25 شركه لانك تقدر تعرف كل
موظف ايش سوى بس لما انت عندك عدد موظفين
كبير شويه صعب قياس الانتاجيه بحسب احد
العلماء في جامعه اوكسفورد اللي الى فتره
يشتغل على هذا الموضوع قال انه عندك مثلا
باوروبا مثلا الدنمارك السويد هذول
البلدان يشتغلون 1400 ساعه بالسنه مقابل
العمل في امريكا 1800 ساعه بالسنه على
مؤشر السعاده كانوا
الدنماركيين الدول الاسكندنافيه اسعد
وايضا انتاجيتهم كانت اعلى بساعه من الذين
يعملون في امريكا 18
ساعات ولكنهم اكثر انتاجيه وبالنسبه
ذكرتوها كان هناك ايضا مدخول ثاني انه
يمكن ما نقدر بس نقلل ساعات العمل وخلصنا
يعني مثلا هما
اربع ساعات تركيز تام ممنوع تليفونات
ممنوع رد على ايميلات ممنوع بدون ما
يزيدون ساعات العمل باليوم يعني بدل ما
يعني ضلت على على
ثمان ساعات في اربع ايام ما صارت 40 ساعه
ما زوجوها بس اعتمدوا انه اربع ساعات
تركيز تام بس تشتغل وتركز على التاسكس
اللي عندك هو يمكن يعني كفاءه وجوده العمل
اهم من عبد الساعات يعني بشكل عام انا
حبيت اسالك سمر هل ممكن انه هذا النموذج
يتعمم نشوفه عم بيتعمم في دول اكثر وفي
شركات اكثر خصوصا وانه حتى كورونا قلبت
المفاهيم قلبت مفهوم بانه ما ضروري انه
الموظفين يكونوا في مكان العمل بيقدروا
يعمل بنفس الانتاجيه من البيت فهل ممكن
انه نفس النموذج هذا يتكرر الان
احنا صارنا تقريبا مئه سنه من 1926 نشتغل
بهذا النظام اللي هو ثمان ساعات خمس ايام
بالاسبوع
مدير شركه فورد هو اللي قلل العمل من 6
ايام الى خمس ايام ولاحظ انه زياده
انتاجيه
الاماكن المصنع لا بالعكس هو قلل لك هو
قله فكرت اللي حط خمسه
عندنا ذكاء اصطناعي عندنا كلها ماشيين
زوالات معقوله نظلنا نشتغل بنفس ما
اشتغلوا قبل مئه سنه يعني اكيد حان وقت
التغيير اليوم طبعا انا شويه يعني
احس انه في رسائل مبطنه
ان شاء الله استاذ مامون حميدان هو بشركه
ويكو سالته ممكن تطبقون هذا النظام قال
ايه ليش لا احنا ما كان عندنا طوز الكافيه
لقياس الانتاجيه بس احنا مرحبين بالفكره
مثل ما قلتي اماره الشارقه طبقتها فنلندا
العديد من الدول الاوروبيه اليوم طبقتها
جنوب افريقيا راح تبلش ان شاء الله تجربه
جديده بشهر جون نفس تجربه بريطانيا
حياخذون 6 شهور وهياخذون تقريبا 60 شركه
ويقيسون معدل انذار وبعد 100 سنه حان
الوقت يعني يتغير
وحان الوقت لكي تغيروا كل شيء شكرا جزيلا
شكرا لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
قصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات